yay hello and welcome to this video this
is three minute madness after wow let's
get going with this funky format when
I'm playing incorrect gambits and up to
get away with it yeah this rupee one
this is really not particularly great
but we'll see what happens in three
minutes yes you can afford some things
at least so yeah probably full-scale
development hear it hope that I can
somehow drum up an attack it doesn't
really look like it should work but we
will see ya wonder 95 you probably yeah
maybe still I mean 24 okay yeah somehow
it doesn't feel like rook on b1 help
much but maybe I can get drunk over to
h3 here no in three minutes asus might
be okay I don't know he still has right
now i heerd c5 he cannot play i believe
i have not be 50
okay so let's let's get everything
rolling him c5 okay does that matter not
much also i'm close to sacrificing their
let's let's start with this let's start
with this nod you see they've got h5
know right yeah let's just fire away it
looks very dangerous really very
dangerous maybe it now we already had
something more incisive but this is not
bad this is an important point here the
Queen has no decent square and have no
takes f7 next route g6 is also close to
working now night have 796 those two
moves will work now maybe I'm taking on
f7
King takes Queen in six I don't think
black will survive this I haven't really
calculated it to be honest I was just
thinking cannot be survived King takes
Queen is 610 g7 how do i check mate from
there Queen f7 King edge aid rock g6 mmm
don't see it made yet to be honest jack
is this correct and now I can also yeah
this should actually work out take here
and Queen f7 check shouldn't that work
hmm yeah Jack does check and really does
it work if this check here jack so like
a g3 now or how do we made now cringe is
sex huh time 185 and cringe III okay
this is a bit too much check me okay how
was a good game had to stop three minute
madness checkmating the black king on f4
with this with his attack okay that's
fun not quite sure if it wasn't so
correct probably but in three minutes
you can get away with lots of weird
attacks so next game
yeah they'd let that gambit e by the way
is complete garbage I mean it really is
Black is getting back with the Queen net
the half-open be file is not nearly
enough compensation yeah so I have
requested a new game but it doesn't
materialize I think currently it is
difficult to get games going game
starting because of the soccer
championships of5 yes pretty pretty
pretty tough decision but okay if he
plays like that maybe this is still kind
of feasible okay hmm it seems he doesn't
want to take stuff somehow I could take
you five the whole time but he doesn't
want to take it for whatever reason ok
let's go forward ok it and I want to
keep this
and here yeah so that's prolly kind of
okay even though i didn't i didn't
really refute his opening play which was
probably impossible anyway I have to
make sure that I'm not taking too much
time here the three minute tabcontrol is
something that I'm not so used to and I
sometimes just forget about the clock
yeah it's not very comfortable the night
only four is just very very nice and
it's easy to play for a while very easy
yum so he goes for the simple approach
counseling short I also could have tried
with long castling but this is certainly
the wise choice I'm trying night 36 here
this is the thing possibly know their
form a going again this is not it
recommended but yeah it's three meli
three minute madness so okay okay i
don't quite get it to be honest I mean
it's not bad here but thought rather hmm
okay
ok so what to do here and night looks
nice but it's not quite clear that it's
doing that much for example after night
f4 takes G takes I think I'm okay really
okay again shooting for night f4
mmm what is he doing here nothing to
take it home hg 595 Bishop g5 hmm okay
not ideal to the king here I know it
looks a bit strange but I don't really
see what doing that much in time morning
how do you cover d3 now mr. Scheffer I
guess you don't bad bishops protect good
pawns white resilience Jim I don't know
tougher I probably was good but it
wasn't so so terrible I think ok let's
shoot for a new game again please handle
those openings here with care this is
not recommended f5 against the willow
pass is Ashley monoi yanush game but
this is fine but after Bishop c4 f5 is
really quite bad he didn't try to refute
it at all but believe me it's possible
so request for a new game out game
starting a key bar L ok so what should
you how can we get something aggressive
going this is a funny funny opening I
don't even know what what the English
name is in German it is the harvest
and it's probably not so great but it's
probably sufficient for our three minute
madness getting some pressure here on
this poor now d 5 shooting for before
okay what is he doing here not sure that
III was the most powerful move I think
this is a bit bit on the slow side now
it's not it not easy to handle here this
position really isn't it so okay so
what's the thoughts the deal here I can
try to keep this on a three i have c 3
well it's not really great mc3 but ok a
3 I can play Knight takes d5 I mean I
can do this and at least I've gained
lots of time clockwise I'm in pretty
good shape ya know c3 is interesting huh
c3 takes d5 I can take be too
it doesn't quite work ok moving the
night is possible that it will take
before with this bishop okay I said let
that shoot for c3 it is a funny funny
funny move so he takes on d5 check on
everyone now then or did you I can also
take on be too but this doesn't look
correct Oh takes this this i did have on
the radar at all our canine Teague's
even a taste make some sense okay let's
just recapture him jack yeah so he has
not lost any material direction okay
what's the deal I probably can go to c5
here an idea form my development now is
not great and really not yeah okay
vehicles to be serviced 1195 so that's
not a not a threat at the moment and now
it's good or not be three a half 94 so
all night a for one of the two probably
here maybe a 4chan
so we're canceling or not I think I
should cancel ok we should f 6 or 60
what e55 is also something if I'm at
five let's do it oh if I've actually no
I see that it's not a good idea Kim oh
oh wow time morning who did i do here
what did i do to my good position check
oh my unbelievable I have completely
blended this away a completely winning
position Wow check check Wow didn't
promote check wait for it okay yeah that
time time is playing a big role in three
minute but wow I was already screwed up
terribly had a pretty much full exchange
but whoa okay so this is a third win
good squad yeah 2300 is what soon I can
get usually with my wacky play in three
minute but still some point short of
that 27 to be more precise and in order
to start little Plotkin okay come on so
what kind of crazy stuff can i play i
can go for a king's gambit oh not Bishop
c4 here yeah this is a unfortunately a
very solid line
councils I don't really know maybe just
shoot for very quick development shibly
oh okay maybe its aim towards the king
oh he gives me that temple why okay
let's see let's take this temple me not
that this is so so much important but
still quite surprising okay so here
maybe this one 95 now as a possibility
all night to do six actually oh well
like the queen with coming over here
maybe I can do this just stop the Queen
from doing anything on the Kings side we
know 95 is kind of possible yeah 95 now
it's fairly dangerous I think I think
you probably should just take our three
year really wow that's an immensely
cheeky move so night age 70 night f7
what's the deal and then f7 the queen is
actually the queen is covering this
stuff okay so this makes this this whole
madness a little bit more understandable
I can I have to go to age cell which is
kind of funky but still very tricky to
play okay I guess just push it away so
the Queen dare is really really funny
okay some how to how to kill him off
here till you have seven their time
morning Beck doesn't work and now I was
thinking I was completely overlooking
something i wanted to i thought he has
to go you know somewhere else then it
could be three and then i can take up
seven that was my idea but he's got
queen bee three
queen bee three is the problem got him
he added what a shame that was a really
really interesting position and now it's
just just not working at all
not at all unfortunately tween f twin
doesn't work either very unfortunate
check still hoping back check pre-move
madness now check check check why not
God Wow I'd like 33 seconds against
nothing here and then he and
unfortunately let him let him get the
Queen okay anyway a good mad game at
least yeah i think i should have just
one india text somehow i cannot believe
the Queen txt to is crazy I mean really
crazy but ok anyway taught how to say
maybe it does work because it covers f7
so okay I've Creek wrestling game
starting be small okay nice a
grandmaster it makes the choice of the
Latvian not yeah yes he seems to don't
know any of the many refutation so who
is that guy by the
I landed you Dawson okay never seen him
play on the internet interesting it was
a very strong player in the 1980s and
90s he probably still is a good player
but I mean he was a competitor in World
Championship candidate matches famously
losing um I think he lost against him
one match against Devon shook and one
match against chronic and new pretty
pretty clear and pretty clear scored I
mean chrome decanter and one sugars as
good as it gets so no big shame I
definitely was a lot quicker here than
him and kind of surprised that he's so
high rated if he plays in that speed but
yea quality can quality of moves can
help quite a lot even if you are very
very slow check
yeah 93 nope looked ok actually there
was no particular reason to avoid it but
ok so yeah that looks a little bit
awkward yeah didn't see Queen g4 and I
definitely don't want to play g5 ok but
after I guess pretty awful oh I thought
that he actually has that covered oh I
can the Latvian against the strong
Grandmaster is too much it's just a
losing opening and losing is it's tough
if you lose with best play just Bishop
d3 yeah can can afford those second-rate
books I guess it's just too bad ok at
least I have a threat now night h3h
five-set possible I don't know
hmm I thought Kevin this is not looking
great but I felt I was already in more
trouble earlier which eight who what
what what about this here I can also
play 92 here go to one shake
I don't see you in time morning yes this
I drooped g6 possibly i know i have to
play I could a good no Tanya check check
I is godrick age 7 I forgot about that
one I damn it ok check I'm now oh it was
kind of getting away with this right he
somewhat didn't want to win and now I'm
kind of in the game but this doesn't
work just lose us huh yeah ok one more
game and that's it the other let vienes
I mean this is probably just too bad i
mean i mean ii actually play in a pretty
pretty bad line in comparison but it's
still a bad position yet you still have
weaknesses and it's all it's just bad
game olivia is too much so give me a new
game please
yeah it's also easy to keep a good
balance there between somewhat crazy and
at least somewhat playable game starting
chaos 23 yeah that's easy that's easy
here you can play full scale pre-move
madness chaos 23 i can give you chaos
absolutely chaos is possible let's go
here we go so what's the deal here can I
do something direct here probably not ok
let's go back it's actually not so great
he's got 95 ok I need I need light
squared Bishop say like Bishop here to
see four or something at least he cannot
just cancel normal as some f2 is hanging
I actually could have taken here I like
to do this now after you play Bishop
between night takes also was possible oh
well okay this is not so bad I get to
check out too but how did the bishop
wrong let's take it with the bishop okay
maybe just back up
getting night f2 into the mix okay he
wants to escape probably he will be
successful with it but by now I have
some I would have some decent material
who cares about this pawn may be here
shooting for between G 592 stuff so he
prevented this can still check here for
King be one hmm you have to get to get
out of this at one moment ok
this would really care much about us and
his phone is king here wow really isn't
that chap I dangerous I just got Bishop
t2 i forgot about that okay i have this
one threatening on be too so what is
this would be five or something like
takes check I've got tons of checks but
probably nite nite nite F to actually
look everyone would be five that's
actually a threat maybe thats thats i
can do this if he takes on f2 i take be
one Queen B to mate and if it takes be
five I check on a one group be one Queen
a3 is also made that looks dangerous
even though I haven't calculated it
fully yeah fire first then asked
questions this is the property in the
right attitude in three minute you know
I don't really see a defense there might
be one but I don't see it at the moment
currently this say I can check there and
have em check now check should be okay
huh I mean okay is a it's more than okay
Queen B one mate it's tough to check
they prevent yeah I was I think pretty
fitting end to this session yeah firing
with h5 yeah okay and three minute chess
it's it's more bullet than anything so
initiative counts for a lot and time
yeah don't really analyze the games it's
not a good idea I hope you were
entertained by some of the crazy games
thanks for watching guys